hi I'm Chris Hardwick co-host of Wired
science on PBS st. probably sitting
there wondering yourself how might I
acquire another set-top box for my home
theater pile TiVo got that sling box got
that Apple TV but we've actually found
another device that will help you while
away hours of valuable inventing minutes
zoning out in front of your television
this week fellow is called the Vudu and
it's basically just like a Blockbuster
video store in a tiny shiny little box
well here's how it works
grab the remote in your hands you select
the movie you want to watch you agree to
a rental fee and then you pretty much
just start watching and that's it but be
warned movies are only gonna be on this
thing for 30 days if they're unwatched
and if you do hit the play button you
only get 24 hours and you pay anywhere
from $1 to $4 and the money is billed
directly to your credit card there are
5,000 movies to choose from all seven
major studios including 20 independents
I mean everything from recent
blockbusters to kung-fu classics to
movies like the lake house that you said
your girlfriend made you go see but you
still went cried a little bit movies of
course are in HD and also in Dolby 5.1
surround sound the unit connects to your
television via HDMI or s-video or other
component ports and the movies don't
actually take that long to download
because they're ultra compressed but
don't worry because quality is actually
pretty passable also Vudu stores each
movie just a tiny little bit of
information on the hard drive and and
sends along the rest of the information
to others of you other users as needed
and this sort of network delivery kind
of helps speed up the download process
it's pretty much like a legalized
version of BitTorrent the innovative
remote attaches comfortably to your hand
like a mutant six digit and there's a
five buttons on here and a nice little
scroll wheel that you can click and the
only bummer thing about voodoo is
there's no way to burn anything
he's on a DVD or get them off onto
another hard drive thanks a lot jerk
but hey hackers guess who's got a fall
project the Voodoo's ease-of-use and
completely top-notch engineering earned
it a 9 out of 10 points and the fall
test issue and a wired best of test
award this is an incredibly wonderfully
time-wasting device because you weren't
really gonna do anything for the next
year or two right for Wired I'm Chris
Hardwick
now please get out of my warehouse